oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back i am
thomas dopizzola whatever you want to
call me i am here with marty o'neal
drastic graphics
guys this is the dope as usual podcast
we're here to talk about life drugs
problems accomplishments and everything
in between today i have a [ __ ]
episode that i'm very excited because
i want to answer some of you guys
questions and who better all right i
marty's been talking about this person
for a very long time telling me all
about them so today we have spencer
snack bundles of dank mark canada yes
sir thank you
canada thc canada yes sir so um
for everyone that doesn't know what's
going on how do you explain what you do
how somebody asked you in the what do
you do for a living what do you do for a
living man
i sell the dankest snacks and weed man
in canada in canada
yeah man and i love what i do
okay so
before we get too into i just wanted to
let everybody know what you're getting
into all right this is the weed episode
we don't do these often so i'm excited
hell yeah man hell yeah so um where are
you from where are you uh born and
raised i was born and raised in
vancouver canada oh uh your whole life
my whole life i moved to new york when i
was uh when i was like 17 18. stayed
there for a couple years then back to
vancouver mima i love vancouver i think
it's the best city in the world
dude me i don't know if you know this
about america most americans are
ignorant we got we are touching we're
neighbors
i just thought it was all white people
in canada i got to be honest i thought
it was all rangers [ __ ] with the hats
that's all we ever see on tv like
canadians bro in south park like bro
what else do i've ever seen there's no
canadian movies bro yeah no we ain't
living like that so what's it like we're
living good out in canada man it's a
it's a major blessing to be out in
canada man we're uh you know the water
is clean the air is good man everyone's
everyone's nice it's a blessing the weed
is real good you know it's a great place
to be so for canada out here in l.a
obviously it's the ogs what is the most
sought after thing out there i mean you
own a read store
so what do you see the most is it the
same like what do you mean what do you
see people going after the most like in
the bay it's all cookies and gelatos
right now
it's the
it's definitely the
exotics
yeah the super hype exotics fritters and
[ __ ] you know the cannabis in the
cannabis game there's
everything goes in waves you know like
when bho first started it was bho and
then you know it was um distillate then
it was like cbd isolate then it was
diamonds for a bit yeah you know what i
mean and then it was like live rosin
that is live rosin right now i would say
it's like the two biggest things right
now are live rosin and super hype um
hybrids i'm meme personally i'm an
old-school gas kind of guy yeah exactly
i like the bubba kush og kush
you know what i'm saying those are like
you know rockstar pink kush like the old
school strains that come from bc those
are my favorite strains still to this
day i'm a gas man yeah same out here so
in la this is the home of og i feel this
is the
the gaseous of gas comes out of here man
i don't know how it's like these
old-school mexican fools are just
pumping it out i would say the two best
gases in the world are from
and vancouver
like california and vancouver yeah
i forget about san fran
they have real good wheat out there yeah
the oakland the bay i feel like the
lower okay it's like humble it comes
down to all the exotic packs are in the
bay and then og's make their way up so
the middle where i'm from from merced is
the dead center california it sucks but
there's halloween
so that's because the fire is coming
from both ways you know what i mean
everybody's taking the trips taking all
their packs down oh yeah everyone in
cali is blessed with the weed out here
man
truly
um so you grew up in vancouver what is
that what's that like for for me i don't
even know about canada what the [ __ ] do
you guys do what do we do man because
you got to remember like we're mad
ignorant out here americans know about
america because are you guys watching
[ __ ] football and [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
we watch football we watch nba we watch
hockey dude we need more canadian [ __ ]
out here honestly man it's so similar to
la like vancouver is so similar to la
it's like it's crazy like it's like a
mini la it's super it's way smaller not
not in size but just like the lifestyle
and the way people live you know like
smoking good um eating healthy like nice
restaurants all that like it's pretty
similar
i take the trip man hell yeah man you
definitely gotta come to vancouver it's
a great place to be man the weed is
super dank you enjoy it out there so you
born and raised out there how's school
and [ __ ] out there you
question were you trapping and [ __ ] as a
kid
was i trapping and [ __ ] as a kid
as a kid um no actually
i was playing ball when i was younger i
was crazy in a basketball that's what
took ended up taking me to new york but
i ended up smoking weed when i moved to
new york for the first time yeah
and from that day i never looked back oh
[ __ ] it's been like 11 years now i
haven't taken a taking a break of weed
man damn it took both of us off the
court god damn straight up same thing
with marty it was the same exactly i was
like i was so like into basketball that
i just stayed away from it you know that
my first day i moved to new york all my
teammates were smoking weed and like
people were already like yo this
canadian guy they're already giving me a
hard time you know so everyone the whole
team was smoking i didn't want to i
don't want to be that guy who's not
smoking i'm like yo do you smoke i'm
like yeah smoke give me that thing you
know i just smoked
man were you replacing three months
later i was kicked off the basketball
team
four months later i was kicked out of
school you know what i mean yep god
let's go change my life
i was like force you to change i was
like you know what [ __ ] this basketball
[ __ ] i'm going to sell weed better than
all you guys you know and the mentality
that's where we differed i was like i'm
going to smoke the shittiest weed
[Laughter]
we changed my life man straight up from
from the time i first smoked in like i
just went all in on it like it just
became my life really though yeah so 17
18 you smoke your weed you get [ __ ]
you fall in love with everybody's friend
that we all hang out with every day
so when do you start selling
when did i start selling weed man
[ __ ]
i started selling weed man
when i was younger and like i don't like
to go into it too deep just because you
know
don't know i know yeah trust me i just
be as vague as you no for sure yeah i
was selling weed since i was a youngster
man since since i went to new york man
and you know it like and i'll be honest
i was never any big time guy or anything
you know it was just a super small time
thing but you know that
just doing its small time i was
i was blessed and i was eventually able
to build it up real slow and over time
and turn it into something legendary you
know so i'm just really grateful i
definitely started from the very bottom
of this weed [ __ ] you know like when i
first started map
i called like a hundred people to for my
first half pound to borrow the money oh
wow i was calling like all my friends i
knew like
family like anyone i knew like yo i need
to borrow 1200 bucks everyone said no
except one guy
god bless that guy he's a good friend of
mine still but he lent it to me
and like literally
everything that i got came from that
half pound you know i flipped that thing
so many times to the point like i turned
that into what it is today you know
without that's my way of like talking
about it without really getting into too
much detail you know because i'm really
blessed in the life that i'm living now
on the legal side of things and like i
just want to
stay on those side of things you know
it's a it's a blessing man for sure i
started off man only smoking the shake
that was left over from the half pound
so you can make more money yeah like i
was so cheap with it you know so like to
take it to where it is now like i'm
still ask these guys man like sometimes
some days i still don't even believe
this [ __ ] is real like i just pull up to
work people are like sending me all
these gifts to try to smoke and like
different flavors i'm like man just even
real life like i remember smoking the
leftover shakes in the bong you know
putting gatorade in the bond because the
weed tasted so good
i've never tried that i'm just super
grateful man that's cool man oh yeah
that's awesome yeah i started off
selling weed uh at lunch one random day
that's really well i smoke let me hit
that that's how it happened you sell
yeah
and that's how it all started for me
it's just it's a long time ago but
that's [ __ ] awesome everything
started from that 1200 bucks yeah man
it's crazy
crazy how things worked out did your
family support you throughout all this
or were they against you
no um
that's actually the reason i started
smoking or like smoking weed and like
getting into the weed business
was i actually got kicked out for
smoking weed like
man when i when i came back from new
york and i was smoking my mom was so
like
upset about it she put like she wanted
me to go to like this drug class when i
went it was like people smoking crack
and [ __ ] you know and i was the only guy
in there for weed and i took i came back
and my mom like there's no way i can do
this [ __ ] man like people next to me are
smoking cracks and [ __ ] like i don't
think weed is what you should what you
should be coming to this class
you should have seen these guys man like
i was like 19 18 i'm like man i don't
want to be around these guys like 45
year old addicts
she's like yo if you don't like if you
don't uh go to the class and stop
smoking weed and [ __ ] she's like you
know you have to live somewhere else oh
[ __ ] yeah and it was crazy man i was
like 19
uh 18 like just turned 19. so so going
to schools yeah so you know moving out
it wasn't illegal in canada though right
it was it was very illegal okay and like
moving out wheat is what saved me man
like
save me and like me is what like i owe
everything to you know even though like
i'm doing the snack [ __ ] now and i don't
really talk about the weed [ __ ] anymore
just because [ __ ] instagram like
senses it so much i don't want to lose
my page just because my page does
a lot of good things for my business so
i stopped really talking about the weed
[ __ ] you already lost the one page right
it was up to like yeah it had a high
amount of followers and i just was
looking for that [ __ ] so yeah i'm just
trying to you know but weed is
definitely like you know
i owe everything to it for sure same
here i love hearing that man everything
i've ever done is from that ten sec
started everything i've ever done it's
[ __ ] crazy to think about like you
said sometimes i wake up is this [ __ ]
[ __ ] real oh yeah man yeah i love
that dude so
you started uh doing your thing
how did you get into the legal aspect of
this
how did i get into legal aspect um
just by
taking taking the long road on all these
endeavors you know like shutting down
like when the when it first happened
we had to shut down and like
close for like a year paying rent
while paying around you know what i'm
saying and going through all all that
paperwork and all that stuff so it takes
a lot it takes a lot of commitment and
financials
and just like patience to get through it
and to make that cross but
you know that was always something that
was the dream of mine was to be on the
legal side of the wee thing you know i
think it's way better i love paying
taxes on it you know even though i make
you know even though you make less it's
just a blessing to pay taxes on it and
like do everything by the book i like
doing everything by the book and it's
cool
so i just want to keep staying on this
wave you know i feel like you use your
bank card a lot hell yeah same here i'm
like nah i want to i i told you the
other day i love paying taxes because i
know i can go to sleep going i'm going
to [ __ ] jail
no i still trip out using my bank card
it's having it it's a new thing for me
you know having a bank card and [ __ ]
like i still trip out using it but it's
a blessing i love it yeah i i love but
how many how much more taxes you want
i'll [ __ ] cough it up that's how i
feel every day man
man yeah i just caught up on all my [ __ ]
finally i feel like an adult now so i'm
trying to like yeah man pay your taxes
man yeah that's the number one thing
take away from this pay your [ __ ]
taxes whether you're trapping it out or
not straight up i always like to pay
them even just a little bit more
than what they want just keep like a
little bit extra you know
take that you know
i wonder how different it is in canada
like i i'm interested
yeah it's the same [ __ ] there's a lot of
taxes if you own your own business here
it's right back we both own multiple
businesses and you end up giving [ __ ]
half the money you make away basically
that's fine i'm fine with that i don't
have health insurance too as long as
everybody else has to
like is everybody else paying it all
right [ __ ] it i'll pay it i do live i i
drive on the roads
no hold on i gotta ask you were you
playing college basketball in new york
because if we were playing against each
other
where did you play i played at damon
college in media college in buffalo d2
where yo i played in the university in
albany so like two hours out
and um what years
um in
2008. oh okay i'm a little bit older
than you i was a 405. where we go
but to be honest man i won't i won't
even cap like i didn't even really get
to play because like i got kicked off
this team so quick because you had to
keep your grades to a certain level to
be eligible to play you know
and like as soon as i started smoking
weed like i stopped going to all my
classes
you know i was just like smoking weed
all day like doing my thing with it you
know so it's what happened sorry it just
the second i started smoking weed i was
a 4.0 student
for two years straight straight a's
i hit the weed i got my first bee
i started smoking out of little pipes
and you know little bomb was that
youtube making little [ __ ] makeshift
[ __ ] oh yeah man i've been through
everything in the weed game man i you
know you got your gravity bung you got
your
um
hot knifes you got your oh that's what i
never typed
your bongs i've tried it all man
i've literally gone through every stage
like you know that stage when you the
only time you can smoke is like if you
have four homies and everyone goes five
bucks each of course you know like i
come from
those days so like you know you
literally been through it all you at one
point you tried everything to make the
week that 20 bag last as long as
possible you know yeah zero it hold it
until it comes back playing baseball and
chat yeah that was fun though all the
homies used to do that like yo you're
wasting the smoke man keep it here keep
it put in your shirts
damn i forgot about those days man
now we're all smoking our individual
joints i feel [ __ ] so dull right now
you got your own ashtrays
true huh
that is a trip
i actually had like at one point i had
my own roller
for somebody rolling you [ __ ] yeah
she's a legend gets tedious man
sometimes like you can you roll four
joints real quick i gotta go do this
meeting real quick i'll be out
yeah so i get it it's just dope when
you've like
when you like smoking like this but like
when you started
smoking real humbly you know and like it
goes up you can really appreciate it
when you smell yes i can't i can't throw
wheat away because there's my fortune i
always say my 14 year old self would
beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] sure and you don't
got to go on some goddamn adventures
permission to get the tent set [ __ ] a
daily mission i've taken my dad's car
when he was asleep i've done many things
to go get some [ __ ] weed
so out in canada
um so since i don't know much about this
out in canada you said it's mad illegal
out there when you were a kid it was
it was illegal like like new york
illegal like this was going to jail
illegal for a nickel sack type of show
okay
uh
definitely new york was as tight as [ __ ]
back in the day i remember my homies
going to jail for yeah a nickel bag like
we never smoked outside one time in new
york because like you literally if you
did you had to like always watch around
and [ __ ] it wasn't on that level
but before they legalized it in some
cities like especially the city i was in
they would arrest you if you had wheat
on you and you're smoking they would
arrest you for sure yeah um
but um yeah now it's legal so we don't
got to worry about that [ __ ] how was
that day
how was that day where the day went
legal the day went legal it was actually
a [ __ ]
party day super shitty day for me ah it
was probably one of the worst days of my
life if i had to be honest with you why
just because that was the day like
um
that they mandated all the stores who
were open at the time to close by to get
their license and become legal you know
what i mean so
that day was actually like the last day
of what i consider the best era of
cannabis in wawa west in in canadian
history like that was a time when you
know i i used to work with small time
independent growers that i could just go
to their place
hand pick the bud sometimes or like get
just get all the best stuff bring it
back to the shop jar it up put it out
you know like prop 215 days what we
would call that here yeah there was no
like middle man and stuff it was the
best era
you know so when we had to close that
day on legalization it was a
heartbreaking day you know i spent like
two weeks before that day
like not even sleeping because i i
couldn't decide if i should stay open or
if i should close and like fight it out
you know but
i did end up closing that day and it
should it lasted for almost two years
bro paying rent
like over eight thousand a month for two
years like
well you know you don't have a business
in there like you guys can do the math
it sucks you know but
when you want to go legal you gotta do
certain things and you know deal with
certain setbacks and [ __ ] like that what
level were you crushing it on prior to
that with your story was it like balling
or was it like a mom oh yeah it was
crazy it was it was crazy i'm still
really blessed for what we're doing now
like the fact that we figured it out in
this legal game i'm still blessed but
like in the old days it was crazy man
like it was wild
just because
people still like haven't fully come
around to the legal weed concept like
all the real og smokers and [ __ ] back in
my city like they're still grabbing off
their vans you know for sure they're not
they're not going to the weed stores yet
so it's like we definitely lost like a
huge demographic of people because
before i used to
put so much care and like attention into
all the products we were buying now we
order things you don't even see it until
you get it you know before
but homie couldn't leave until you
inspected the pack under a magnifying
lens you smoked one to test the flush
you know what i mean you gave it the
full rundown now it's like we ordered
things from a website i can't
um tell how it is before i get it so no
matter what i'm gonna have to sell it so
at a certain point
even though when we get things that
aren't up to code we put it for sale
right away there's still
room for error now in the legal market
because we have to still sell those
things that aren't dank you know but
back in the day it's like nothing hit
the shelf without it being super super
certified dank yeah guys i was just
talking to this about marty uh i'm just
talking about this too marty
i was uh like i said i used to sell weed
and [ __ ] but i have a lot of friends
that own dispensaries and shops i
remember the days
where some random mexican dude walk in
with two duffel bags like you guys
buying today and they just sit there and
inspect everything like all right what's
a little short i'm gonna knock a little
while and everybody can make money back
well that was the everyday thing yeah
everyone made money well people used to
just pull up you even know garbage bags
stuff yeah you don't even know you know
what though like i don't want to glorify
that era too much it was fun though
because it was fun it was super dope but
like there are certain pros of this side
for sure you know like the fact that
people didn't give invoices and all that
back in the day and then like having to
do your books and stuff it was just a
nightmare you know now at least like
everything is on paper so it's like
navigating that aspect is way cleaner
now you know you don't gotta worry is
too much everything's pretty
straightforward now yeah no i would
never i wouldn't trade back
it was fun but the cons are
yo i didn't check every nugget there's
[ __ ] mold and bud rot in the bigger
nugs i didn't break them open [ __ ]
you i know you've had that happen you're
like oh this pack is perfect and they
leave like oh my god this bud rod in
this [ __ ] there's been many times you
gotta call home me up like yo yo by the
way you need to come pick this up like
there's no way i can sell this obviously
we used to have the magnifying lens so
we're looking at everything inspecting
the pack yeah they have that one that
that is on the little table with a
little arm yeah yeah actually yeah she
was dope oh yeah
all right cool so that was one of my
questions and were you selling weed
beforehand yes so how long have you
actually had your store before it even
went legal
man
uh
many years man yeah many years it was a
store people just walked up it was like
just just like an la shop like you can
just walk up
prop 215 no card
how it started back in the day
um
you know we were one we were one of like
the earliest stories around back in the
day opening it up opening up meant you
were like kind of protesting you know
like that you were like
kind of like i know it's fine it's like
saying yo weed should be legal like
we're taking a stand back then it really
meant taking a risk selling weed like
now all the people that get into it
a lot a lot of these corporate guys like
you know
they're not like from the same people
like us like when we really had to take
risks yeah you know opening up shop it
wasn't illegal there was no business
license for wheat you actually just had
to open up you know and take a chance
and just start selling weed
you know it was crazy man trap shops the
way we used to do it back in the day
like everyone knows we used to have like
a doctor that would sign um
medical things you know so we used to
have the doctor in the shop and people
would come in see the doctor they would
get a license from her and then or they
would get this form signed and then they
would get the card from us and then
there would be a member you know what i
mean you just have to put their
prescription on the wall no we would
keep it oh okay i remember those things
he did things like even though it wasn't
a
um
fully legalized time we still tried to
do everything by the book like we didn't
let people come in without doctor's
notes we tried to keep everything super
medical
and then it turned into
legal legalize now so now we don't need
to do all that people can just walk
right in and buy now you know they just
have to have a id that says they're 19.
[Music]
being an owner of the shop prior to
being legal and now legal
what do you like best
i mean besides if money factor was taken
out do you like the structure of being
legal better
that's a tough
it's a tough call i would i would say
it's better for the
finances side of things like the
bookkeeping and accounting but it's just
man the way they have it right now like
the way we order product it's just
really annoying man like we literally
have to just order from a website and
like
they only allow us to get like two cases
of each product
two cases that's like sometimes it's
only 12 in a in a case so we're talking
about 24 units so if the strains really
fire sometimes we might be limited to 24
units you know like we're selling in a
day oh we used to sell pounds of one
strain in a day you know you tell me i
only got 24 units for a whole week
potentially like it's crazy so
things like that just
um i really miss i really miss being
able to really take care of my patients
and like to the fullest degree
i'm still doing it now like the legalize
it's it's still cool but it's not where
it was yeah you know i still think that
it's going to be a few years before we
get to that point where it was before
legal legalization find a balance you
know what i mean yeah because the thing
i i've noticed now is where are all the
the like heady growers at
where did all those packs go do you know
what i'm saying as soon as it went legal
it's like all the
small-time growers just took a licensing
deal or something and now they're under
another name but you can't find the fire
anymore i for me i'm just struggling out
here i can't i found one decent solid
flushable everything pack in a year yeah
i'll be honest man since i got here i've
been a little disappointed with the weed
i won't even lie i'm still safe yo if
anyone watches now lay man hit me up
next time if you got like some special
smoke because they're careful you're
gonna get 9 000 people asking yo by the
way yo about my uncle hey my cousin
personals i like you know just a couple
of grabs or you know oh guys whatever
just for me to smoke because
since i've been out here there hasn't
been that many strains that i've been
like yo
but this is my personal yeah and it's
been really overpriced it's been crazy
man yeah everything right now is cust
it's custy city
i have been buying eights because i
can't find [ __ ] bags for the first
time in my life and it feels so odd
looking around and seeing people buy
weed just
i just want to go to my friend's garage
and buy a pound of weed right now like i
can't that aspect's missing i've even
been smoking uh legal weed lately
yeah there's been there's actually some
good legal weave yeah this is legal weed
but
i feel odd like
well one jar is gone one joint
[ __ ] seventy dollars
seventy dollars cookie store with my man
campaign over there and we paid seven
hundred dollars an ounce for all the new
cookie strains cocaine prices yo when
you uh convert that over to canadian
that's almost like a thousand dollars
you know what i'm saying so
16 000 i know you were mentioning
earlier homie had the thousand dollar
zips
but um
you know i felt like i was getting
robbed man yeah i can't let anybody hold
me down and go i had to do it because we
were going to a trade show
and
i just didn't want to
take the chance of not having weed to
smoke that whole weekend you made the
decision because i heard the right
decision you know but um
yeah i was really disappointed how old
are you i'm thirty thirty yeah say man
oh [ __ ] i'm 31 actually oh did you
forget already yeah oh that's it started
i'm smoked out oh man
no i do that all the time i always go 20
i'm [ __ ] 32. oh my god i'm gonna
throw up i just hit me [ __ ]
it's different huh
32. i just turned through yeah i'm
turning 32
i feel like i'm 25. dude i always forget
i forgot look at miracle 24
[ __ ] man crazy time flew
fast bro what's your birthday uh january
bro oh yes you're right behind me man
yeah so i don't know just the [ __ ]
you're saying i didn't know canadian
dudes are going through the same [ __ ] we
are oh yeah the same aspect you just
talked about the struggles is all the
[ __ ] i watched my friends do all the
fools that own shops just like
just get [ __ ] all the time but back
then
that's what came with it man it was a
risk every day like oh we got ready
today but you know i just dumped the
safe so we'll open up again next week
yeah man it definitely hasn't been easy
but we're here now so we're just trying
to expand now that's awesome man
so thc canada is what it's called yeah
it used to be called the healing center
um this is in vancouver where
that's the name that i love like that's
my baby the name the healing center i
love that name and my slogan was
dedicated to keep you medicated
it was trademark too i liked it
but
um when things got legalized they
actually wouldn't allow me to say
healing and they wouldn't allow me to
stay medicated so i had to abandon raise
my two babies like i love those things
around the healing center it's just thc
the healing center you know it just
sounds so
nice you know
hey man you sure you're not writing
lyrics with marty over here because
everything you just said was bomb ass
wordplay thc the hill is dedicated
[Music]
i had to switch it to thc canada just to
keep
like what is like known in my city is
like the logo my square logo so my goal
was just to be able to keep that square
logo you know so i i had to abandon
healing and all that but i just kept thc
okay you know so doesn't it stand for
the hustle continues though no it
doesn't that's
that's just uh that's some other [ __ ] no
that's just a slogan that
we i thought i started it but then i
seen juicy j named his album that so i'm
like obviously people were other people
were saying it but you know that's just
like
um something that kind of defines our
life like we've been through a lot of
[ __ ] it's a mindset in the last couple
years you know like things that
would have stopped most people's mission
you know but you know we just gotta say
the hustle continues keep it moving yeah
don't let anything stop you spencer's
become this huge figure online
especially for kids in canada that
people look up to like you
by inspiring people for [ __ ] pushing
through from been watching them for
years that's good though man you started
that you started that [ __ ] when you were
in your early 20s and now you're
starting to
see like
the benefits of putting all that were
you always on social media or did you
just kind of embrace that recently um
i wasn't always on social media like i
started getting into it big
more like when dank mart started coming
out oh okay but that's pretty recently
that's like the past year everybody's
always on it like don't get me wrong but
like i've started like really noticing
the value of it more and like i've
started tapping into it more and
treating it more like a job now before
it was just like something i was just
doing like you know oh yeah smoked out
chilling yeah posting nug shots and like
some videos of me smoking all day you
know now it's kind of turned into
something that actually can you turn
your mic towards you a little bit i'm
sorry
just cutting out
now i've kind of
[Music]
you know what what were we talking about
it went from you taking pictures of your
weight being a brand new yeah so yeah
now i've kind of just realized what it
can really do for you if you treat it
more as a as a job and you know i got a
great team behind me you know we're
gonna have schedules now
do videos on certain days you know like
write things down in notebooks i'm
always bugging this guy i'm like yo get
a notebook like there's so many ideas
that we have and like have to execute on
sometimes it just gets crazy but
we uh we're starting to do a really good
job of organizing all that and you know
trying to take things to the next level
well marty sent me the page and like i
said and you know mario i'd be like oh
it was it was good it was cool you know
me and after by gay they need help
asking about i love what you guys are
doing thanks i [ __ ] love the colors i
love the logo i love the popping out i
love the cleanliness of each [ __ ]
aisle everything's put together it looks
like
hey hurry up and grab everything you
want let's get the [ __ ] out of here
because you don't have to sit there for
30 minutes and just look around and then
the social media with you like i was
talking um
the little videos you were doing just
packing the exotic candy just packing
the sodas just packing this it's
it's your commercial for yourself and
you had fun while you were doing it at
your own work it's a win all the way
around yeah honestly man it's a genius
the biggest thing for me is just having
fun with what i'm doing so even like
those videos like i'm gonna try to do
things that are like you know funny just
showing the true me like just having fun
with what i do yeah you know what i mean
so
i always just try to encourage everyone
out there like try to find something
that you're passionate about that like
you enjoy doing that you can like be
smiling while you're doing it because
man life's so short it's like you got to
find something that
if you think about it how much time does
work take out of your life you know it's
like if you can find something that
actually brings you happiness
it's a probably the biggest blessing
dude that was perfect my because my next
question was what's your advice to young
entrepreneurs
that's literally it right there that's
that
you know because yeah you just want to
it's a difference when you wake up every
morning and you're passionate about
something
and the work ethics yeah it's just a
different feeling like you're just
naturally going to work hard for
something because you're doing something
you like doing it you know you're
passionate about it compared to like if
you're somewhere and you hate what you
do because i've been there before where
i hated what what i did and like
it's like you know what was your first
job
man i had so many jobs really did really
yeah good [ __ ] i had so many jobs man i
worked at like a chicken restaurant i
worked at like a sporting goods store
you know what i mean i worked at like a
skate shop at one time like there's just
so many little jobs that i had like
that i
until i got to once i found wheat it was
just like i didn't do anything else i
just went all in on wheat you know i
just put everything else behind me and
just double down on weed you know good
[ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] yeah that was my other
questions like did you have jobs before
you just [ __ ] stand there can't wait
to get high this is boring and then you
found what you did for sure and like i
just realized i like um you know being
my own boss and
i don't really like working for someone
that's when i started getting in the
weed [ __ ] that's what i really learned
you know and i
just um
was so fortunate to turn it into a
business you know yeah for sure for sure
also i feel like
just from i've never met you before
i feel like you're a perfectionist
i am yeah yeah okay i could tell
everything he's saying is like that's
what i tell people i'm a perfectionist
because that's why i feel like you'll be
working till one in the morning you'll
be back at nine for sure bro right crazy
hours man like you have to though for
sure when i first started i didn't even
have employees
you know just work every day
all day open to close and like
my employees make fun of me like you can
ask bro here like everyone says i'm like
ocd
like but i think that's i think that's
something that's really important for
stories man is just to have like that
cleanliness and like that vibe to it
like
smell good you know like i i just think
all those things are huge components of
like a successful store but in terms of
brand identity though what i love is
like you got two adjoining stores next
to each other oh yeah please get into
this thank you thank you you just nailed
it in terms of they both have their own
look and feel but they go together like
you're gonna get the people coming in
for the weed and the thc it's got the
super clean aesthetic the whites the
purples really super clean they're gonna
go next door to your specialty snack
shop anyway but then it was so smart to
open the snack shop that opens it up to
the world any age make it fun it's not
even weed-based but like
and it has its own brand identity i
could do a whole course on this for
school on how you executed this i've
only been watching them for like a year
or two what he's talking about is like
he's he's been expanding and scaling
this so quickly
that's supposed to be like damn just he
keeps getting it out yeah it's just it's
the apple store for candy and [ __ ]
that's what i look when i looked at like
damn that [ __ ] is organized like i said
like it's organized it's hella clean
this makes you want to go in there do
you have a good business degree
uh no man
i didn't last in school like yeah
kicked out right away just in a few
months i got oh yeah yeah yeah all my
degrees were degrees [ __ ]
learning yeah yourself learning about
making mistakes
you know what i mean it's so crazy sorry
what i'm taking away from this is people
in other countries are doing exactly the
same [ __ ] we were doing every struggle
you just talked about every perfection
oh i had hella job i worked in
restaurants i worked
same exact i [ __ ] love hearing it man
wearing man it's seeing you in a success
i'm not saying don't go to school by any
means school's cool oh no for sure yeah
i was just never able to pay attention
in school like since day one i never was
able to but i'm just so grateful i was
still able to uh be successful and do
something legendary and dank without
going to school
so if you didn't do this you'd probably
be
working for the city or doing something
or running some type of business
somewhere for someone else
if i didn't go to new york i don't know
what i'd be doing
i'm saying like i feel like with the
mentality you have you would have at
least been running something else no for
sure you know what i'm saying you're not
going to be the guy like oh bring your
car in i'll change your time i don't
know what it really would have been when
that's great man
straight up man i honestly don't know
i don't want to sell myself sell my self
short or anything but i just feel like
weed was the thing man like i was just
that was my calling in life might have
been a [ __ ] starting point guard for
the lakers or some [ __ ]
you know what i don't think so man i
don't think that was my calling man you
know ophelia i [ __ ] feel you i
realize that going out to new york i
used to be in new york um just like
playing ball training every day
getting up shots
working out i'd be playing at rutgers
park and then a dude would come in he
was just selling
selling weed on the corner all day he
just comes in
no practice no nothing he's like dunking
over me like shooting
all right man you know what [ __ ] this
hoop [ __ ] i'm gonna sell weed better
than all you [ __ ] out here man
i don't
you know what i mean and yeah just weed
was i think i think that was my calling
in life man it's yo
i stopped playing football i'm like bro
i'm not tall enough to [ __ ] make it
i'm not 6-2 i'm a lineman
i'm [ __ ] over and that's why i quit
football i was like i like weed too much
and i'm starting to sell weed so i'm
done with sports straight up that's
exactly what happened to me what the
[ __ ] is going on me too now this is
crazy
yo what a parallel [ __ ] universe
going on over here
hey what's up guys welcome to our
mid-roll ad read we want to say a
special shout out to one of our sponsors
manscaped and if you watch our podcast
you already know what manscape's about
and if you don't here we go this is the
mail grooming kit this is the mail
grooming brand everything you need to
make your dig not look gross i'm gonna
give you a little breakdown of the
products they offer it's not just a
razor there's so much more and no it's
not like a big razor this thing is
actually technologically advanced it's
skin safe it's wireless charging it's
has a light on it it's waterproof so no
excuse not to take care of yourself
introducing brand new to manscaped this
is the body wash and it's the shampoo
conditioner combo now they have stuff
for the rest of your body all right this
is shampoo conditioner combo and the
body wash so if you want to check out
any of the manscaped products go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola or
if you go on the link right in the
description of this video whether you're
on spotify apple doesn't matter or
youtube check that out or it's in the
linked comment on youtube click that
link that's going to go directly to the
discount like i said if not
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off your whole order and free
shipping guys christmas is around the
corner which scares the [ __ ] out of me
because this year just flew by but chris
is around the corner if you want to get
something nice for somebody performance
package is pretty damn awesome thank you
guys so much for supporting the people
that support us i'm going to say it
every time because we honestly
we mean it all right thank you so much
for clicking the links thank you for
buying manscape whether it's a gift if
it's for yourself thank you for
supporting the people that are
supporting our show
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off plus free shipping or
click the link in any of the
descriptions
hey what's up guys taking a quick moment
to say thank you to one of our sponsors
this is on it we've been working with on
it for a few months now and guys it's
something that i've incorporated into my
vitamins it's just that the alpha brain
is something i'm taking all the time
they have shroom tech new mood alpha
brain they have if you like whey protein
they have whey protein before i get into
anything else let me tell you exactly
where to go what to do if it interests
you at all go to
www.aunit.com that's onnit.com
forward slash yola or type the code yola
that's going to give you 10 off of
everything in the entire store except
for the weights all the supplements all
the gear and like i said before they
have some badass shirt design so if this
just go check it out just click apparel
and go look and something i've never
really talked about before this is on it
has their own academy their own online
academy where they show you i mean just
a string of workouts stuff that you
for me honestly from experience it's
hard for me to think of a routine what
do i do besides like the [ __ ] they
showed me in pe they've done a tutorial
for every single product they have the
kettlebells the bars the
the ropes every single thing that you
can think of that they offer they show
you how to use human optimization
they're not just selling you something
and go just lift it a bunch of times now
they're giving you a bunch of really
high high quality content just so you
know exactly what you're doing and
you're not hurting yourself first off
and so you know what you're doing
there's lectures videos tutorials
everything these are trained
professionals also if you're a fitness
instructor and you want to get audit
certified you can actually do that just
go check out the website again before i
go
www.aunit.com that's
onnit.com forward slash yola or use the
code yola at checkout click the link in
our description anything it's always
pinned in our description or pin in the
comments that'll give you 10 off of
everything except the weights alright
guys once again thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the video
it's weird that's crazy bro yeah
we're all blessed by the planet you know
for sure dude i just i love hearing
someone else's story like this it's very
and you're in the weed industry so
you don't get a lot of this a lot of
people that own these stores
were working in finances for 40 years
they're like oh i have you know my
retirement to put in on this [ __ ] it's
not often you see someone younger
actually doing what you're supposed to
be doing and it works yeah man for sure
now i'm blessed like
um i'm like more focusing on the snack
game right now i'm trying to like taking
a back seat on the wheat on all the weed
stuff right now but you still have your
store going stop my story going but i'm
just so grateful i have a real good team
you can delegate you can expand you can
schedule a good team yeah got my man
campaign back there
um and there's a few more people that
like because they're so good it's
allowed me to like step away and like
focus on the snack stuff because
my bro was the one who was uh
you know the man for the snack store but
then he passed away
and
you know now i just feel like with what
happened i got to like step up you know
so
i took a i stepped away from the weed
stuff to go all in on the snack stuff
for a bit that was my brother like he uh
he
oh
you meant your brother you're talking
about yeah
we had the other store together like i
wasn't even working at the snack store
when it first opened i was because i i
always just worked at my weed store you
know which are right next door right
yeah but then uh you know after all that
happened it was just like i had to focus
on the snack store now i actually love
the snack game you know it's really cool
it's a super dank industry and i love
what i do every day but
i've also like never forget about the
weed you know like it's always on the
back of my mind i'm always checking in
with my team every day seeing how things
are going and i'll i'll eventually like
get back into it fully but like right
now i'm trying to like scale the snack
stores and like expand them i really
think like it's so yeah it's really
unique and i'm innovating right now i
really think we're the best at what we
do with the snack game
and you know i just feel like weeds kind
of like saturated right now you know
everywhere it's like
i'm still excited about it but not as
much as i used to be if you didn't have
the regulations from the government and
[ __ ] you'd probably be way more excited
yeah they've kind of like
they've kind of like taken the fun out
of things just like sure you know yes
it's uh the snack game is real cool
right now so i'm just like going all out
on it
and it's the same thing man it's just
how much you get it for all right let's
do this all right let's make it look
cool all right let me go sick let's make
money except you can sell everybody and
yourself every kid like you know so you
like soda
bro it's it's it's legal weed i'm not
legal weed and to me because i used to
sell weed you saw so much like cool like
unique
stuff you would never specialty stuff is
there something that like is there a
couple things that like sell more than
anything that's from like the 90s or
some [ __ ] that we wouldn't think of the
dunkaroos man i thought oh
dude
i'm selling dunk group packs like
[ __ ] weed packs man like they're
moving like crazy so long yeah man like
right i know as soon as i saw him i was
like
me like fire hair boy oh [ __ ]
like big pallets and pallets and pallets
of them like you're selling [ __ ] like
that at the store oh yeah like no i mean
like that we we've sold so many like so
you're e-commerce thousands of thousands
of dunkers is it an e-commerce business
yeah we also do worldwide shipping yeah
that's why you were doing the little box
setups yeah
we do
that's a good christmas present
[ __ ] all right
surprise your friend what's up dunkaroos
www.dankmart.ca
where we just bought.com so that's going
to be available soon too but yeah we do
uh worldwide shipping we also do free
local delivery so we got like the dank
mark cars on the road [ __ ] two
free local delivery yeah and he just
opened a second location correct yeah
man the second day yeah the same city
yeah and then we're gonna open one up in
toronto and then i'm out here in la
because i want to open it up in l.a too
so i'm just like out here kind of
getting like a lay of the land you know
just kind of understanding like what
areas are nice and like kind of just
putting the initial groundwork into that
expansion awesome
i low-key just want to do it because i'm
a huge lakers fan and i want to have a
reason to always be down here and just
go to all the games and you know yeah
why not i mean why not see how far you
can take for sure so i saw your story
the other day
i saw your story the other day and this
fool's over here blowing the whole spot
up on espn
was so legendary awesome dude i don't
know why i was telling my bro this other
day that was like one of the most
proudest moments of my life like that's
how you know i'm a true stoner like like
that was one of my proudest moments
please explain please for everyone that
doesn't know what's going on yo so i
went to the lakers game and it was like
the first uh game of the season so they
had like the nba tonight show there like
shaq
um kenny whatever
kenny smith ernie you know the whole
crew
and um
yeah it was just i was they were doing
their thing doing the show and i lit up
the fattest joint like an extra king
size and it was some super gas like some
laog you know like that you know that
that hybrid smoke it doesn't really
stink up the joy it doesn't like
it really just stinks up like that
skunky like you know gassy like fuely
smoke you know
yo and these guys wouldn't stop talking
about it on the tonight show like they
literally talked about it for a minute
like yo i'm gonna have to change my
clothes after this like [ __ ] i feel like
yo i'm gonna have to get a drug test
after this you know uh on the show i
don't know
shaq said this yeah i watched the clip
on silent i was just looking for him
clouds in the background because you're
behind forever there's no it's outside i
kind of got into like a little like um
argument with shaq
and now there's a rumor shaq's looking
for me in l.a and that he wants to
square up with me and he wants to fight
me what did you do yo so shaq if you're
watching this i'm not
i'm down you know
watching again
i don't know if you see my story but i
called him out i'm like oh i didn't see
that i'm like yo
i can i might be able to find it in my
stories i'll show you after
some [ __ ] god damn i can show you yeah
i'll show you and then i just yelled at
um shaq i'm like
yo shaq man
if you hit those free throws he wouldn't
have four rings man
i'm like yo if you hit your free throws
we would have had four rings like
meaning kobe would have had four rings
he looked around he [ __ ] stared at me
for like a minute and then he got up and
kept looking at me like he was he was
serious man
no no
i thought i was gonna have to throw it
on with shaq
loki i never forgave him for what he the
things that he did to kobe after he left
the lakers like
he made like a rapture a die-hard fan
i'm a die-hard kobe fan die-hard lakers
fan i'll never forgive shaq for what he
did to kobe man after that like even
though like you know he shows love for
now like i'm just like die hard kobe man
yeah you're a gee god damn you wear blue
clouds and we're talking about [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] the shacks
suck at free throws oh my god you can
hear it on tv then yeah you can hear
him getting [ __ ] on i didn't realize
they were talking about it it was a
legendary moment man for like me i'm
just such an mba fan like that's where
they smoke out the nba tonight show
that's right i know it's like something
so minor but it's just you plan on doing
that or was that some spur at the moment
no it was some super spare the moment we
just walked up and i seen them there and
we had this huge fatty so i'm like yo
what better and no one was in front of
them i'm like yo no one's standing in
front of them i'm like yo let's spark up
so i just started sparking up and doing
the camera and then people started
coming up to me like yo you should
listen to what they're saying he's like
yo shaq said it smells like snoop dogg's
back here
[ __ ] and then we were just laughing and
it was just a funny moment man that's
amazing that's [ __ ] i'd be so hyped
we're talking about that you know some
stoner [ __ ] just hyped up that's exactly
what it is it's stoners like that was me
my weed's fire yeah you know when you're
just a true stoner like when you smoke
you like you want people to say you
smell like you're like yo i got reeks
like yeah that reeks man that's that
good [ __ ] you know
sometimes sometimes
nah bro it's not me
i'm at the airport shut the [ __ ] up yeah
okay the airport is the one excuse other
than that i love smelling like me
[ __ ] yeah i don't care anymore man
yeah that was a kid i did the airport
though yeah man definitely want to get
some fresh clothes on before you go
there you know kobe was chuckling
somewhere off in paradise like this
[ __ ] oh yeah man bro so shaq's
trying to fight you i'm so excited for
you no joke man like i'm ready that's
scary i feel i see him
i know what you
but i'm just saying if you really had to
fight shaq just go for those knees
yeah just go for those knees and run
away
sweep the leg and run yeah man i don't
know what i'll do obviously it's not
looking good for me
but uh
you know let's go
it is what it is
you've got an epic [ __ ] trip god damn
yeah it's been a dope trip we went to
vegas man oh mj basically how was it it
was cool man it was definitely like a
lot of growing and extract extracting
[ __ ] but like it was still cool to
network we met a lot of cool people
there and like
um you know it was dope getting home was
hectic
when we got there too like
because i went to the lakers game first
we drove on the road right after to
vegas and i ate it edible before we left
so when i got there i was so high and it
was like four a.m when we checked in and
then like yeah we sold your room to
someone what the hell
dude i got a whole different room it was
like the shittiest room ever
and the hand man on the way back i was
telling this guy for like a week before
he laughed i'm like yo
let go figure out a way home we can get
home
man damn we were [ __ ] sitting on the
side of the road our bags are like
trying to call people all these services
we're like you know we can't do it
because it was edc weekend oh my god i
went to college i went to call it uber
it was like two grand instead of like
300 bucks racks so yo so me and this guy
we called this this guy found a bus that
was in vegas it was like yo
one of the most grimiest buses and
they stopped in this place like two
hours from vegas this guy googles it
when we're there it's like the highest
crime rate in all the [ __ ] uh in the
united states
he's like yo they're like
oh my god did they go get off the bus
for 20 minutes we're like chilling there
with all our stuff i'm there with this
[ __ ]
there was this white blind [ __ ] i got my
chain on and [ __ ] you know
i'm like you're asked to get
but it was cool we just smoked a joy man
i was just laughing it was just funny
man it was just a funny experience the
bus was packed like the lakers just
riding back it was just like
it was just a funny experience like we
just made it to the bus within like one
minute and like it's cool because like
you know nowadays i've been blessed to
have made like a little bit of money so
i usually now like travel like in nicer
means and like you know like right
so it was fun it was like dope to like
go back to the days you know like being
on the bus like like when i used to be
in school i used to always take the bus
places like you know go visit new cities
and [ __ ] it was cool you know it was
just a cool experience i was just
sitting there like laughing super high
on the bus like you know what like
it was hectic
we had to like rush all over town to
make it we just made it but it was dope
you know and then we got back to l.a
came here
and now we're here
i love that sounds like trains planes
and automobiles the [ __ ] movie it was
an adventure man bro i think it's funny
you go from exotic dope ass [ __ ]
laker game [ __ ] shaq yeah to the bomb
ass [ __ ] las vegas to them going sit
down outside all right you're getting
the [ __ ] that's the shittiest oh yeah
man
it was it was dope it's good it's a good
it's a great cool thing is i was telling
junior over here i was just telling him
i'm like you know what i'm proud of it's
like we just laughed through it all you
know like all these curveballs and like
things like we just kept smoking and
laughing through it all like no matter
what like we never let anyone ruin it
for us we still had an amazing time you
know we just
like i feel like sometimes you just
gotta make the best out of all these
little situations you know because
sometimes i feel like
uh we stress about [ __ ] that's not
really that
worth stressing over you know sometimes
you just gotta step back and be like yo
it's not really a big deal let's just
figure this [ __ ] out you know
and just smoking joint almost always you
know most things in life yeah just smoke
a joint left that's all you could do man
you're driving there all stressed the
[ __ ] out you're trying to stress kills
you man straight up man stress is like
probably the one of the worst things you
should always try to avoid yeah you know
like
like i feel like there's too much stress
around you just need to step back it's
in a lot of people
daily lifestyles too with their jobs
like getting their stress being they're
stressful going home i don't even like
to say the word stress anymore
because i feel like you're just putting
that out there you know yeah i'm gonna
say he might be the chillest
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life oh
yeah
i don't even say the word stress man i
don't
exactly what smoke it
about i consider that like a swear word
about hey
don't say that
yeah man don't say that word in my house
man i don't want to hear that [ __ ] i
don't even want that [ __ ] around me yeah
you know like
the [ __ ] i've been through this year
like for me to stay in this like happy
zone that i'm in like you gotta you
gotta do a lot of [ __ ] it takes a lot
you know little things like that and
just like being uh choosy with your
energy and who you
where you're around and [ __ ] you know
that's my biggest thing i've worked on
lately is
people around you really do [ __ ] rub
off like people's energies and vibes for
sure real
and
you only have so much time in the day
man i've i've realized now that i'm on a
schedule with everything
you have to be choosing your time wisely
and who do you spend it with you know
who my favorite person to spend my time
with
and i do spend more time with than
anyone is my dog i just straight up like
like to work and go home and smoke weed
with my dog man he's the most chillest
coolest [ __ ] of all time
oh come on he's the coolest dude of all
time
and like straight up man like that's who
i like spending my time with man what a
dog do you get i have a yellow lab nice
he's just the coolest cool ass dog
he's just like he likes to smoke weed
and [ __ ] like oh he's one of those dogs
eat cbd and [ __ ] he's a cool dude he
likes you know my dog smokes weed and
[ __ ] he's got like old personality i
love it what's his name his name's
harlem because i used to live in harlem
in new york nice i you know gave him
that name
yes honestly like
my bro like my bro was the only person i
ever hung out with you know for like the
last 11 years or whatever so after he
passed man if
it wasn't for my dog man i don't even
know if i'd be here today man he like
it's crazy what dogs can do for you bro
like when especially when you're going
through like such a emotional like
depressing like time in your life a dog
can like actually lift your spirits up
and like you know make you laugh
sometimes and [ __ ] when like you just
like feel like crying and like you're
crying and [ __ ] like a dog can do things
that like no one else can do
a good dog you know what i'm saying
yeah straight up man man's best friend
yeah
literally you just said it my lab that i
grew up with was that to my dad while he
was dying there we go yeah like no for i
know exactly what you mean he worked in
my weed store too like he's a cool ass
dog he used to serve up bud for people
and [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] no cats walk on two legs
holy [ __ ] you should serve bags for
people man in his mouth people used to
walk in the store and his paws would be
on the counter like this like he'd be
like yo like greeting you like he was an
actual bud tender [ __ ] you know
amazing no joke people would come in the
store be like yo was harlem working and
then we'd be like yo he's not in today
and then like yo we're gonna come back
tomorrow
wow there you go you only come in with
the dogs
a lot of dispensers yeah they never got
served a sec
he's a legend man he's a legend in uh
that neighborhood man
damn
yo canada i wanna go to canada bro their
dogs [ __ ] sell weed out
you guys
active mascot employees
i love this this is amazing he was
actually on the payroll and everything
are you [ __ ] here
oh okay i thought you were dead [ __ ]
serious right now you got a brand new
holy
[ __ ] wow
yeah benefits and all that
that's hilarious yo i love this so much
and now i want to go to canada i really
want to go to canada now it's not that
far from here to our flight that's crazy
oh yeah i was talking about driving i
always say toronto to me is like the
cleanest nicest biggest city i've ever
been to like a clean manhattan was
vancouver like that too yeah hell yeah
bro
he show your friend
yeah
vancouver would you say vancouver is it
like as like clean and fresh and modern
as toronto is or seemed at least it's
way cleaner than toronto though
i didn't do some research we're a
million times cleaner than toronto man
i've only seen dudley do right
i swear to god that's all i know about
canada i don't know yeah he's all i know
about [ __ ] vancouver and [ __ ] pal
gasol and [ __ ] back in the day i don't
even know oh he never played for
vancouver man oh i'm sorry from memphis
oh god come on they were vancouver yeah
they were vancouver's connection you
know memphis stole vancouver grizzlies
from us yeah they robbed us man the
power wasn't up there wait that was one
of the biggest robberies left from your
town to go to memphis tennessee
who the [ __ ] wants to go to memphis
tennessee
anyways [ __ ] the grizzlies man
we lakers on this side yeah yeah lots of
grizzlies man [ __ ] memphis grizzlies
yo that's the avid basketball watching
right yeah i like this this is great bro
he's gonna be on the cover of [ __ ]
slam magazine talking all this [ __ ] yeah
yo you know what you should do like shaq
i'll let you punch me if you can make
three [ __ ] free throws in a row and
then i'll shoot and without i get to
punch you
yeah but you're hilarious for bong for a
shot
any situation of shock punching me no i
would hurt her
no he's going to be honest if i seen
shaq and he really want to screw up i'm
probably [ __ ] run i'm probably out of
there running straight up man i'm not
going to lie to you don't prove you
sound like i'm buddy some tough guy no
man anytime you try to be that guy it
always goes bad man no i'd like i shot
i'm out of here man
could you imagine
i can i did sleep
i would just run yeah
under something like yeah get under here
like running from a t-rex and jurassic
park yeah i just get in a tunnel
somewhere and that would have his arms
trying to come in
you got to go double tasers and you just
look like you're dumb
that's your only chance man i'll call it
we're gonna get the [ __ ] out of here
uber get the [ __ ] out of there [ __ ]
baby d his ass until the uber gets there
yeah
come on
smoke weed you could blow up the [ __ ]
cloud in this for you sorry yeah pull
out a fat black like yo you smoke oh bro
i'm sorry i'm imagining you fighting
jack and it's the funniest [ __ ] i've
ever seen it's a cartoon yeah i can see
it and it's not even real
sorry shaq
come on the podcast though shaq let's
clean this up just sit a little back
bro
i would tell them because zam should
have got an oscar
and then they would have thrown
everything off
yeah he'd been like what the what the
[ __ ] even i know that's not true
he's talking [ __ ] your album should have
got a [ __ ] grammy bro that [ __ ] was
snugged i will fool was better than
[ __ ] yeah
yo gotta be honest though now that you
bring up shazam
i was mad poor when i was a kid so when
those hamburgers fell from the sky i was
like yo if that [ __ ] happened to me
do you remember when he's like i wish
for hamburgers and pizza and it all just
starts dropping in
bro that's the only part of the whole
movie i remember
i don't remember [ __ ] about that movie
that's the yeah i don't think that's
actually
anything about the poster of it maybe i
watched i played shack foot i played the
[ __ ] i never played that though yeah
i never played that man i got it the
same day i got boyz demand cooley high
harmony my first cd yeah
man this guy's really yeah marty's
worries about it was it the first cd you
bought or the first cd you got
what's the first thing you got or bought
that was probably my i don't know it was
my first cd my first real cassettes were
all eyes on me crazy sexy cool
my cousin gave him to me that's what i
had first yeah man i grew up on
cassettes too what's the first thing you
ever bought yourself with your because
you know when you went with your own
money to buy something that was your
[ __ ] cd tupac all eyes on me let's go
that doubled the double dude yeah yeah
it came with two cassettes at the time
my mom had that one the first thing i
ever bought with my own money was
bloodhound gang hooray for boobies
that's a good i remember those guys
yo they're funny songs their actual
music is quite their main song though it
was the uh bad touch the mammals the
doom remember tom greenshire right or
whatever uh they
i remember that i would say bloodhound
gang has an extensive cd collection you
guys should all check out but the first
he ever got was please please me by the
beatles on my sixth birthday
okay yeah good [ __ ] good [ __ ] how much
hip-hop on [ __ ] doo-wop and chat yeah
my mom is always playing two-pocket [ __ ]
tupac we're big or uh no sorry odb
i miss those days man i miss burning cds
oh yeah i never i never figured it out i
just had my friends do it i just
couldn't do it limewire downloading
songs headlines did you listen to like
completely american music coming up or
because i mean i know you had cardinal
official you had some canadians man i
wasn't listening to no canadian rappers
going on that yeah i figured i'm just
saying all american rappers yeah i
figured i was so influenced by like you
know by the states growing up yeah only
a couple hours away for sure yeah
so influenced by new york rap like
that's actually why like i ended up
going out there
was because i had better situations like
to play in like other places but it was
like delaware or like idaho and [ __ ] and
i seen oh you're you were you that good
at basketball they were trying to tell
you to go to school it was like smaller
schools like but still like you're good
enough like yo well you should go to the
school and play basketball yeah they
were junior colleges i'm not going to
[ __ ] lie here like that's not good
mark's the same [ __ ] that's exactly what
he did but uh then i ended up going to
new york so i'm like yo that [ __ ] looks
so dope like in all the movies and all
the rap songs like jay-z gnaws and [ __ ]
like
you know just it was dope
how about can i get like
top five albums from like 96 to 06
coming up my top five albums of all time
[ __ ] that's tough even just top like
what comes to mind coming like comes to
mind definitely tupac all eyes on me is
up there like the first one you got damn
like um
jay-z reasonable doubt
is one of my favorite albums
nas illimatic marty don't hang out all
the time you guys are the same [ __ ]
person different hat right now is what
i'm saying you guys are talking about
this i know marty well you guys are so
much alike it's [ __ ] killing me right
now it's crazy bro that's this full
sorry to me and then i'd probably say
nipsy hustle the crenshaw album
you too
that's his favorite person of all time
yeah word yo me too
oh [ __ ] yo
no no joke man yeah i'll be i'd be
straight up honest man without nipsy i
wouldn't have anything bro um like
straight up oh mentality yeah man like
he uh he was so instrumental in my life
like
just like when from when i first got his
album i was one of the first hundred
people to get his album oh [ __ ] i got
that one yeah i have it framed in my
house you got 100 albums yeah like it's
framed in my house and uh you talk about
that often actually changed my life man
that was like the bible you know like
it like gave us a lot of game and like
blueprints because
when i first got kicked out and like
first started getting in the game or
whatever
getting in the wii game getting to
understand it
um
people weren't really telling you that
you could do like this legendary [ __ ]
and like set up businesses like the
people that were around me at least
they're all like idiots that were around
me you know but then when you listen to
nip he's telling you like yo you can
start a business from this if you save
your money and don't spend your money
foolishly and like he was telling you
all these things that no one's really
telling you you know like not even in
school they tell you this [ __ ] you know
like so without him like i don't know if
i would ever have that like
super super inspiration to like do all
the [ __ ] that i'm doing he he like kind
of like
helped me find it within myself you know
so i always say that like without nip i
don't know if we'd be here today um
which is crazy to say yeah no it
it's crazy to say to people it sounds
crazy to people that don't understand
the influence that positivity can really
bring because he's one of those artists
that you are with for like you know
many phases of their life he just said
you have told me before yeah yeah
which is unfucking real yeah you
literally talk
it's a mirrored situation right here
marty have said the same thing it was it
was like for me like me and my brother
growing up and [ __ ] he was our guy we
always listened to together and [ __ ] but
then i kind of when i stopped rapping
and [ __ ] i was kind of fell off even
listening to rap for a while the first
couple years i was out here getting in
the heavy into podcasting and comedy but
then when he died it was like
snap me back into my [ __ ] self in
some weird way
where i was like i don't know it just
reminded me of who i was and made me
inspired to want to inspire people and
like
made me want my own [ __ ] i was working
for so many other people i was like i
need my own [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what's next in the long term
so it was like his death had a big
impact on just
making me hungry again because when i
stopped doing music and got into
podcasts and comedy drastic graphics
full-time
i didn't have that like
burning confidence i had in music
i'm never i'm never like i'm the best
graphic designer all [ __ ] time yeah i
didn't have it like that you know you
know what's wild for me yo like the
three people that i've mentioned in this
um podcast the three people that like
really changed my life like my brother
nipsey and kobe they all died to me
within one year of each other yeah
you know what i mean like i lost all the
three people like obviously my brother i
loved the most
i love my brother more than anyone in
the world history like more than even my
own blood anyone you know
and then like i love kobe and and nip
like they were my brothers you know like
i had like i felt like i had a real
connection to them just how much you
know i watched them and like how much
they inspired and motivated me and just
to like lose all three of them in a year
like
it was [ __ ]
heartbreaking man like now we got a
mural of all three of them in the store
you know but
it's just like
just those three just like really
inspire me now and motivate me to keep
going
on days when shit's like
feels a little hard you know yeah
for sure because it does get hard shit's
real and life is real
so yeah for you that that is a big hit
man that's crazy that all that happens
in
what your 30th year
now you feel like a [ __ ] adult
while he's blowing up and realizing his
dreams though yeah man and it's
you're on the path man that you're
saying crazy obviously my brother's
passing was like you know the the
biggest but like still like all three of
them like when nip died like i actually
felt like i lost a family member you
know and when kobe died it was just like
it was like
couldn't breathe you know it was like
the most saddest [ __ ] of all time like
for sure you know i just say remember i
was sitting for both of them it just
reminds you life is short be grateful
for every day you know what i mean don't
let the small stuff weigh you down don't
let this like don't sweat over the small
stuff and stay happy stay laughing keep
it moving and grooving
smoke some good weed enjoy every day
let's go you know what i'm saying sound
bite right there
i love that
well i thank you for [ __ ] coming on
here for real for everyone at home
you're [ __ ] welcome this is the
[ __ ] episode that we needed hell yeah
this is the episode that a lot of people
needed to hear you know you're saying it
inspires me just makes me feel like i
know
you are becoming something like that for
other people it's a blueprint like you
said it's a it's a blueprint it's the
template of you can be cool happy and
still be successful
by yourself you don't mean like on your
own terms you don't have to go
you have to work i used to work at the
pizza spot mcdonald's all the [ __ ] and
none of it was mine
you know what i'm saying it's not yours
at the end of the day well for sure and
that's
that's a big part of everything i do
like i just want to inspire people to
do what they love to do
whatever it is you know whether that's
like opening a restaurant or like being
a website designer just like i just feel
like man everyone should just try to
find something they like to do you know
i honestly think that's like one of the
biggest blessings in life when you
actually find that thing
you know
and it's rare that you get to make money
doing exactly what you want and then if
you can make money off it then you're
laughing yeah and you're smoking weed
just [ __ ] with shaq in l.a talking
[ __ ] to [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying yeah my life is
super blessed man i i'm super grateful
man
i'm super grateful to be here in la
yeah man so what would be like i don't
know if you look this far ahead but like
if everything were to go correctly five
years from now what would how would it
roll out for your master plan of what
you got going on how you keep scaling
your businesses
um i think it would look like a bunch
more of dank marts and thcs together all
over
canada and in the states you know and i
want to sell out
and then i just want to chill
[ __ ] yeah
straight up man i want to sell like you
can get that 100 mil you know that yeah
like you can kind of get them
yeah you know i've been approached man
like i've been approached to
sell the stores so many times
but you know i bet it on myself like
even though the talks were like in the
millions like saying no to a million
like even a million when you're like you
know 29.
you know it's yeah it's it's hard man
you know what i'm saying but i'm betting
on myself one day hopefully that it can
be more than that that's why i'm doing
all this work now but
you know i'm 31 i've been on this grind
every day since i was down to 19.
so like let's go i'm not i'm i'm not
like one of those old people that like
say i'll never retire you know like all
the retire in the future like four or
five years if the money is right [ __ ]
man i've already given 16 years of my
life to this game every day of all go
chill and like that's the different path
in life you sign up for oh yeah because
the average man signs up for well i'm
gonna have my weekends i'll get out at
five and they'll have me for the rest of
my life we sign up for some
a different path in life where it's like
i'm going to give my every waking moment
to this so that i can chill on the back
half of my life yeah i'm on yeah not
just talking
i've been doing this the last 11 years
like a few hours here and there like i'm
talking about 24 7. 25 8. yeah you've
never seen
like
yeah sleeps all existence sometimes man
damn near a lot like
all my relationships get messed up just
because i'm always working you know it's
just like it's crazy
but i mean that's what you're here for
so when you're 45 you go
[ __ ] yeah i've been sitting for five
years and i'm rich as [ __ ] that's the
whole goal because when you're when you
grow up poor you just want to go
can i just buy you guys houses you guys
are chill you guys are chilly i'm gonna
go [ __ ] lay down finally no for sure
and i was blessed man my fam was like
super hard working and [ __ ] you know so
they were
doing the thing but i was just blessed
because
my fam was so against weed you know they
were like the biggest weed haters in the
world you know they thought weed was
like smoking crack
so i was
it's crazy man i ended up like i didn't
talk to my mom for like two years after
she kicked me out and then we ended up
opening a store and then she came and
she was proud as [ __ ]
and then she ended up making edibles for
my store let's go her 360 her turnaround
or whatever was one of the biggest
turnarounds i've ever seen in my life
she ended up making edibles for my store
because after she came and checked out
the store she's like yo
she's seen a documentary for it and she
seemed like kids were getting cured and
[ __ ] from it so she's like yo i've been
getting lied to about weed my whole life
oh [ __ ] like this [ __ ] is actually
pretty cool you know like it's not super
bad
you know and then uh yeah she ended up
making one of the most famous popular
edibles in my store history oh [ __ ] nice
she loved that video she ended up
getting so mad milo she found out how
much i was selling them for and she
stopped making them
me and my own mom got into the [ __ ]
beef in the week came over she used to
make the dankest banana bread yo and
like people used to like line up early
in the morning for it outside our store
we had two famous edibles at our store
that this was before back in the days
when you could make your own edibles you
know we had a medicated jamaican patty
oh dude and we had this medicated banana
bread these two things like people used
to line up outside our store in the
morning to make sure they got them fresh
you know it was just like a legendary
thing
and then they stopped all that so now
you can't do that [ __ ] anymore but shout
out to your mom oh yeah that's tight
dude
[ __ ] yeah um
so where can everybody find you at
where can everyone find me at the video
uh there's stores in canada yeah yo you
can find me on instagram snack bundles
we'll we'll uh link it hell yeah and
then
um dank mart uh on instagram
d-a-n-k-m-a-r-t
and then for my cannabis store thc
canada it says thc canada so you can
find me on all three of those and you
can link to the websites you can order
um snacks worldwide thank
mark.ca.ca and we just bought
dankmart.com yeah as well
so soon when you type in dangmart.com
it's going to go to the main website so
you can ship to the states yeah we ship
worldwide yeah i saw the stuff you guys
i know it's sugar i know i get it but
come on bro it feels like some of this
[ __ ] you have in there i feel like a
little as cute
it's like a collectible exactly you got
some
i'll show you guys your box yo i'll ship
you guys a box nice [ __ ] yeah we'll open
it up and we'll eat it on the show hell
yeah thank you
um i just want to say thank you thank
you for
doing what you're doing this is this is
cool this is a
the positivity path is is so less taken
you know what i'm saying you don't have
to [ __ ] on everybody to be successful
you just got to work [ __ ] hard and
keep doing what you're doing so yeah
[ __ ] bro yeah if i had if i can just say
another tip it would just be stay humble
you know like treat everyone with
respect that's like one thing that i've
learned it's just like you gotta treat
everyone with love with respect doesn't
matter if he's you know a janitor if
he's like you know some big boss you
actually everyone and it'll take you a
long way in life just being humble and
showing everyone love you know yeah
exactly dude uh on or off camera guys by
the way
be nice and cool to everybody whether
you know what i'm saying like no just do
it for [ __ ] ig like yo here's a
[ __ ] homeless guy here's some money
some real [ __ ] so no it
that's why i [ __ ] with marty so heavy
same [ __ ] he's a good dude yeah shout
out to marty for getting me on this
podcast man [ __ ] yeah yeah hell yeah i
mean it just came together it was random
i was in the airport on my way back from
nashville and he told me
first guest of the season so many of my
followers were um super like hyped that
i was doing this you got a lot of
canadian fans and hell yeah shout out to
canada i'm just grateful that i came
here because just walking in that
hallway i was telling you this earlier
i'm just so inspired and i'm so
motivated just being here in that
hallway like what you guys have built
with that is super inspiring and like
it's gonna
really motivate me when i get home to
get on my grind and like go hard with my
youtube channel good [ __ ] anything you
guys need you know the tips help [ __ ]
some structure or whatever hell yeah bro
feel free
for sure
thank you so much for being on the show
man i don't guys i don't even know how
long we've been on here i have no idea
about a buck 20. oh good [ __ ] huh all
right all right well thank you so much
like i said uh dankmart.ca if you want
to check that out guys thank you so much
for watching thank you for being on the
show thank you thank you for coming
thank you for chilling thank you for the
uh
the um
stash jar appreciation
but thank you for all that [ __ ]
and we got you before you leave the
whole
just give me your size and we'll walk
through the warehouse
appreciate you
mario anything else
i'm just so glad we were able to make
this happen we got the canadian
connection
the canadian connection
i like that [ __ ] first one i knew you
know what i mean i wanted to make i knew
our fans like it's just so in line this
is perfect this is this interview
exactly it's it's
because it's about weed but it's about
entrepreneurship and it's about that's
why i was most excited i think it was
legendary talk straight like that bro i
really appreciate you
talking about everything and then thank
you for being vague about the weed thing
because i've had somebody go yo bro
should i say that i'm like we'll have to
go back and cut it out [ __ ] damn
you you're cautious just like me so good
[ __ ] why am i two people these days are
like so opposite of that everyone wants
to just like talk about everything you
know and like put their all their
business out there some things you
cannot say yeah yeah i'm old school man
yeah some things that's why that's what
bob has a mask on some things are better
left unsaid and some people's faces are
better left blurred straight out man
thank you so much for being on the show
guys uh
i'm [ __ ] high sorry i'm uh thank you
guys so much for watching this has been
episode two season two the dopes usual
podcast have a dope as day
i'm [ __ ] high bro that was a
loved it i don't even remember what we
talked about yeah i'm [ __ ] hot thank
you so much thank you appreciate it it
was an honor to be on here man
good [ __ ]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]